ce matin avant de parler bien sûr
longuement de cette consultation des
maires un consultation vous êtes à
l'origine on va parler de l'actualité
rouen suite des conséquences de
l'incendié l'inquiétude reste bien sûr
vivre sur place hier edouard philippe a
promis la transparence il ya une
commission d' enquête qui devrait voir
le jour au sénat la semaine prochaine
pour vous c'est une bonne chose
c'est absolument indispensable celle
attentes profondes des habitants de
rouen et de l'agglomération rouennaise
il est toujours plus difficile de
rassurer que d'inquiéter bien sûr il
faut pas faire de la surenchère dans les
informations anxiogène il faut la vérité
je crois que le premier ministre dit les
choses justement quand il parle de
transparence mais ce qui est très
difficile pour les rouennais
c'est justement qu'on fait la
transparence et pour le moment les
informations ne sont pas suffisantes
elles ne peuvent pas l'être d'ailleurs
il faut le temps des analyses il faut le
temps de la vérification mais pendant
tout ce temps là on peut comprendre que
nos concitoyens de normandie soit
réellement inquiet dit le gouvernement
ne peut pas faire plus il fait ce qu'il
faut ce que je dis c'est que dans toutes
ces crises sanitaires moi j'ai été
associé près du président chirac à la
gestion des suites de la crise de la
vache folle mais dans toute crise
sanitaire
il y à un moment précis et nous sommes
dans ce moment aujourd'hui où le
gouvernement
les experts eux mêmes n'ont pas réponse
à toutes les questions et c'est la
raison pour laquelle faire la lumière ça
passe aussi par le rôle du parlement par
le rôle du sénat
quand nous décidons ici de faire une
commission denquête nous voulons
apporter une contribution avec le recul
qui est le nôtre
avec cette capacité d'indépendance dans
l'étude du phénomène n'est pas plus
crédible elle a parlé oui on est puis
oui bien sûr parce que tout gouvernement
c'est pas celui là en particulier
il est en situation d'autorité de
gestion et donc au fond pour faire face
à ce type de crise il ya besoin d'un
regard indépendant le sénat qui est par
définition une assemblée parlementaire
indépendante et non alignés
il a cette capacité de regarder le fond
des choses et de dire la vérité en tout
en toute indépendance
autre sujet aujourd'hui c'est emmanuel
macron qui va lancer la concertation
citoyenne sur la réforme des retraites
il sera à rodez pour vous c'est
important de consulter les français sur
cette réforme ou le travail qu'a fait
jean paul delevoye qui a consulté les
mêmes pendant 18 mois suffit on ne
consulte jamais trop les français
moi ce qui me frappe dans cette réforme
c'est que elle est fondée sur une
attention qui paraît positive mais qui
pose mal le problème au fond on nous dit
il faut que chaque euro cotisé donne les
mêmes droits en matière de retraite tout
ça est très séduisant mais le vrai
problème de la retraite
aujourd'hui c'est pas celui-là c'est
quelle retraite je vais avoir si je
prends ma retraite dans 20 ans et
comment faire pour durablement assurer
l'équilibré financier des retraites
or c'est le seul sujet que les pouvoirs
publics nous disent en réalité ne pas
vouloir traiter
moi je veux bien qu'on fasse des efforts
comme on les a appelés systémique
c'est un c'est un mot qui fait
impression mais moi c'est pas c'est pas
le système
il m'intéresse c'est le financement des
retraites est là encore j'ai été au côté
de simone veil en 93 pour la première
réforme des retraites il se trouve que
j'ai été aux côtés de jacques chirac et
de jean pierre raffarin en 2003 pour la
seconde de réforme des retraites que
portait françois fillon la réforme des
retraites c'est toujours à remettre sur
le métier et il faut garantir aux gens
leur retraite pour sécuriser leurs
présents vous savez si les gens se
disent j'aurais pas une retraite alors
ils ne consomment pas parce qu'ils sont
obligés d'épargner davantage et c'est
toute l'économie qui en souffre
tellement il n'a pas le choix il faut
reculer l'âge de départ et ceux qui
souffrent le plus des perspectives de
déséquilibre financier des retraites
c'est les plus pauvres privés dans le
cadre supérieur
il s'est constitué un patrimoine quand
il part la retraite il a plus besoin de
payer de loyer il a sa maison son
appartement
c'est pas la même chose donc moi je veux
dire que il faut absolument ne pas se
tromper de combat
en matière de retraite et et oui il faut
prendre des mesures qui garantissent le
financement ya pas de mystère
vous vivez plus longtemps mieux que les
générations précédentes et donc
finalement il ya une forme de
convergence entre le besoin
d'accomplissement personnel qui passe
souvent encore heureusement d'ailleurs
par le travail qui n'est pas une corvée
sauf quand vous avez travaillé dur
depuis le plus jeune âge et que vous
êtes épuisé
et là il faut en tenir compte mais il ya
une convergence entre ce besoin d'être
présent dans la société et actif et ce
besoin que nous cotisions davantage pour
garantir de bonnes retraites
allez on va passer aux sujets qui vous
concernent de près en philippe bas cette
consultation que vous avez lancé au nom
de la commission des lois grande
consultation auprès de tous les maires
de france hier vous en avez dévoilé les
résultats on regarde les principaux
enseignements avec béatrice faisant ils
sont 3812 avoir répondu à la
consultation lancée par la commission
des lois du sénat le 13 août dernier sur
les 36000 maires de france sollicité
10,9 pour cent de participation
c'est un maire sur dix est le premier
constat est affligeant
92% des élus qui ont répondu au
questionnaire ont déjà été victimes
d'incivilités d'injures de menaces ou
d'agressions physiques
or moins de la moitié vont jusqu'à
porter plainte des plaintes qui
n'aboutissent à la condamnation pénale
que dans un cas sur cinq objectifs de
cette consultation mesurer l'insécurité
des maires pour apporter des
propositions présentées par la
commission des lois
les maires parce qu'ils détiennent
celle de l'autorité publique sont
exposées sont nombreux à se sentir seuls
abandonnés et sans moyens pour lutter
contre les violences dont leurs réponses
au questionnaire atteste qu elles sont
très nombreuses
aujourd'hui il faut leur donner un coup
d'arrêt un plan d'action donc qui
s'articule autour de douze mesures
visant à renforcer l'autorité des maires
conforter leurs moyens d'action et mieux
les protéger dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions il faut qu'il y ait davantage
d'amande qu'ils soient pas des amendes
pénales c2d prononcé par tribunal mais d
abord administratif c'est à dire
prononcé par le maire
la commission va d'ailleurs amender le
projet de loi engagement et proximité
afin d'y intégrer les dites mesures déjà
transmises au gouvernement afin qu'elle
soit appliquée au plus vite
on va parler en ce projet de loi sur un
statut d'élu non quelques instants mais
d'abord sur les résultats de cette
consultation 92 % des mères qui ont
répondu à notre questionnaire se disent
victimes de violences ou d'agression est
ce que pour vous c'est le reflet de la
triste réalité où c'est un chiffre à
nuancer vous dites que seuls les maires
victimes d'agressions répondu à notre
questionnaire c'est pas un sondage ça
c'est certain
c'est à dire que d'un sondage vous
prenez scientifiquement à l'échantillon
représentatif mais c'est mieux qu'à
sondages d'une certaine façon parce que
c'est une mesure grandeur nature
évidemment on plutôt répondu des maires
qu'ils étaient victimes d'agressions
c'est évident enfin 3812 réponse on n'a
jamais vu çà vous je n'avais pas fixé
d'objectif j'attendais de voir les
réponses nous nous disions avant d'agir
il faut connaître
c'est pour ça que nous avons fait ce
questionnaire en plein mois d'août après
le décès tragique du maire de signes et
nous avons fait très vite pour exploiter
les réponses qu'ils ont confirmé fond ce
que nous savions nous sénateurs parce
que nous sommes en contact des élus
quotidiennement que le problème n'est
pas marginal le problème n'est pas
anecdotique
tic il y a un profond sentiment
d'insécurité et en + 60 % des réponses
nous disent ça s'aggrave la cote
d'alerté franchi et nous nous voulons
donner un coup d'arrêt à ça parce qu'il
n'est pas acceptable
vous savez dans une commune rurale le
maire c'est un citoyen habitant parmi
les autres il accepte de se dévouer
il n'est pas en train de faire une
carrière politique il va s'occuper de
changer les fenêtres de la mairie de
remettre de l'asphalté du bitume sur
telle voie d' arbitrer un conflit de
voisinage c'est quelqu'un de dévoué
alors si avec toutes les contraintes de
l'exercice de la fonction de maire vous
avez en plus les incivilités les
agressions les violences la diffamation
sur les réseaux sociaux
ça devient insupportable et donc nous
disons nous la commune
c'est la petite république de la grande
et si la petite république dans la
grande et malade c'est toute la
république qui est malade il ya un
chiffre dans votre questionnaire c'est
que seuls 37% des élus qui vous ont
répondu ont porté plainte après une
attaque dont ils ont été victimes
comment vous l'expliquez est ce que
c'est parce qu'il ya une faiblesse de la
réponse pénale que finalement les élus
ne vont pas porter plainte
je m'explique par un parent vécu que
j'ai le maire assume
il ne veut pas être à charge de sa
commune il ne veut pas demander au
conseil municipal de payer l'avocat
il ne veut pas envenimer les choses
quand il ya eu une violence il encaisse
moi je dis aux maires non il faut que
vous agissiez il faut que vous portiez
plainte et je dis il faut pas que vous
ayez à devoir vous soumettre à une
décision du conseil municipal il faut
que l'assistance par une assurance
obligatoire soit automatique sauf
opposition du conseil municipal bien sûr
pour y avoir des abus il faut être
prudent mais il faut que cette
assistance automatique et il faut que
dans une commune de 1000 habitants
la dépense soit compensée par l'état
parce que le maire n'osera jamais porter
plainte si il faut en portant plainte
sacrifier une partie du budget municipal
dont on a besoin pour des petits travaux
de la commune et moralement
il se sent pas la liberté de faire ça et
du coup on ne donne pas le coup d'arrêt
qu'il faudrait mais surtout une fois que
vous avez porté plainte
20% seulement deux condamnations alors
le maire disent à quoi bon à quoi bon
porter plainte
et puis ils disent aussi au kiel pour
vous il faut une réponse une réponse
judiciaire plus ferme
mais bien entendu ils disent je vais à
la gendarmerie on me répond que au nom
ne transmettra pas la plainte alors que
je suis maire il faut que j'assume que
c'est des risques du métier
non il faut au contraire comme le fait
d'ailleurs pour un policier ou un
gendarme qui est agressé on a raison de
le faire et maintenant pour un bon pied
parce que les pompiers sont agressés
aussi enfin quand vous représenter
l'autorité publique au service des
autres il faut que cette autorité soit
protégé pas seulement pour vous même
mais dans l'intérêt du bon
fonctionnement de nos collectivités de
la démocratie allez on a vu le constat
avec vous fait débat on va maintenant
voir les solutions vous avez fait des
propositions mais il ya la loi de
sébastien lecornu long engagement
proximité qui était examiné en
commission hier au sénat on va en parler
avec notre journaliste parlementaire
alexandre tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour rien bonjour philippe bas alors
je vois le corps nu qui était examinée
en l'air en commission les sénateurs ont
enrichi un ce projet de la wii la
commission du des lois du sénat enrichi
ce projet doit avec notamment des
mesures sur la sécurité des mers qui
sont issus de cette grande consultation
dont vous parliez avec par exemple la
possibilité pour le maire de se voir
déléguer le pouvoir de fermer des débits
de boissons et des établissements de
musique si c'est nécessaire par exemple
pour les voitures abandonnées pour sur
la voie publique le maire pourra
prononcer une astreinte de 50 euros par
jour
et puis tous les élus municipaux
pourront bénéficier de cette assurance
qui financent leur protection juridique
il ya aussi des mesures pour encourager
les maires à se représenter un fait
reconnu de la crise des vocations
et oui car à la base c'était l'objectif
premier de ce projet de loi
alors le texte du gouvernement sur le
volet indemnités des maires prévoyait
d'augmenter de 150% les indemnités des
maires des petites communes de moins de
500 habitants la la commission des lois
un peu
recadrés résonner les choses elle
prévoit une hausse de 50% pour ces élus
en particulier
et puis une hausse de 30% pour les
maires des communes entre 500 et 1000
habitants sur les frais de garde là les
sénateurs sont plus généreux que le
gouvernement les frais de garde seront
remboursés pour les maires de toutes les
communes de moins de 3500 habitants
et puis le transfert des compétences des
communes aux intercommunalités sera
assoupli il se fera un peu à la carte
c'était une grande demande des maires
car beaucoup se sentent dépossédés de
leur pouvoir face à ces grandes
intercommunalités
merci alex célibat à tout à l'heure à
l'ex ainsi liban on voit le sénat
enrichi ce projet drogue est-ce que
désormais c'est une réponse adaptée au
malaise des mères ce projet de la
lecornu c'est une réponse nécessaire
le cdh a d'ailleurs l'avait donnée il ya
déjà 18 mois et 2 trouvons que le
gouvernement a un petit peu tardé à
s'emparer du sujet mais ça nous vaut
tard que jamais et puis nous essayons de
rehausser le niveau de l'ambition comme
vous l'avez montré il y a un instant
parce que oui c'est lourd d'être mère et
la multiplication des contraintes on ne
parle plus de la violence mais ça on
fait partie ce risque aussi la
multiplication des contraintes par les
normes qui se sont surajoutés et les
difficultés financières des communes par
les dotations qui ont été réduits depuis
qu'ils ont été gelée puis par la réforme
de la taxe d'habitation qui a créé une
énorme incertitude sur le financement
des collectivités va tout ça fait que
avant de rendre ce service que de se
dévouer pour sa commune on y réfléchit à
deux fois et donc il est grand temps de
dire au maire oui nous avons entendu
nous vous donnons des moyens
supplémentaires
évidemment cette loi elle ne peut donner
et qu'une partie de la réponse
il ya des réponses plus importantes à
faire vous savez nous avons déposé mais
oui mais oui le au fond nous pensons
qu'il faut affronter les libertés
locales dans notre pays
à chaque fois qu'on donne des pouvoirs
aux élus locaux
on s'efforce très rapidement de les
rendre aux administrations centrales en
asphyxiant financièrement les
collectivités parler en multipliant les
normes dont parlait il est grand temps
voilà de donner un nouveau souffle sur
les propositions vous avez fait hier
parce que dans votre conférence de
presse il y avait aussi beaucoup de
propositions est ce que vous pensez être
entendu mieux suivis par nos gouvernants
là on revient à la question de la
sécurité parce que c'est celle là qu'on
a traité hier si bellement hier et
qu'est ce que nous disons nous disons
d'abord dans 45% des cas quand il ya
violence ou incivilités
c'est à l'occasion de l'exercice de ses
pouvoirs de police par le maire et c'est
ce qui s'est passé pour le malheureux
maire de signiant mathieu michel qui est
mort brutalement alors qu il faisait son
devoir de maire dans l'intérêt de la
collectivité parce qu'on dépose et des
gravats sur un terrain privé tout de
même et donc les maires se disent mais
alors je je je devrais rester aux abris
et ne pas assumer mon devoir non c'est
pas possible de faire ça du coup nous
disons puisque quand il porte plainte
parce que quelqu'un a violé un arrêté
municipal à ça n'a pas de suite
il va falloir maintenant qu'on fasse en
sorte que au lieu d'aller jusqu'au
tribunal
ce soit la commune elle-même qui puisse
prélever des amendes de sorte que la les
gens se disent ah bah si le maire
constate que je viole l'arrêté municipal
pour un dépôt d'ordures ou que j'occupe
de manière illégale
un terrain je vais prendre tout de suite
la sanction ça c'est très important de
pouvoir garantir sa donc renforcer
l'autorité du maire et que ça se sache
et deuxièmement protéger le maire que le
maire ne soit plus tout seul ça veut
dire que le sous préfet le gendarme le
préfet il doit immédiatement venir au
secours du maire que les plaintes soient
enregistrés que le procureur puisse
saisir le tribunal quand le maire est
agressé pour qu'il y ait un tribunal qui
prononce une peine et surtout dans tous
les cas d'ailleurs que quand la justice
est saisie
elles disent au maire ce qu'elle fait
est qu'elles n'attendent pas que le
maire vient de le lui demandait
mais que ce soit automatique et puis que
la garde des sceaux elle donne une
instruction pour dire dans notre
démocratie c'est pas acceptable de
laisser les mères tout seul je vous
demande
mesdames et messieurs les procureurs de
la république de faire des poursuites
à chaque fois que ça vous paraît plus de
fermeté de la peau mais oui on va
changer de sujet philippe bas mais vous
le savez tous les jours dans cette
émission on se rend dans une rédaction
locale aujourd'hui direction lyon pour
retrouver nos partenaires du progrès
bonjour jean philippe vigouroux
merci d'être avec nous ce matin vous
êtes journaliste au progrès alors vous
allez me parler d'un tout autre sujet
puisque vous allez nous parler fromage
la fourme de montbrison
effectivement nous publions ce matin un
reportage réalisé dans la loire près de
montbrison cette ville du forez est
connu au delà des frontières du
département pour sa forme
il s'agit d'un fromage à pâte persillée
qui obtenu 109 c'est en 1972 et
bénéficie d'une aop depuis 2010 et c'est
justement cette aop cette appellation
d'origine protégée qui aujourd'hui
pointé du doigt l'un des producteurs de
cette forme a récemment claqué la porte
de l'appellation
nous sommes allés à sa rencontre pour
connaître les raisons de cette rupture
jean-philippe rigoureux avec cette
appellation alors nous avons rencontré
hervé guillemin et catherine rio qui
sont à la tête de la ferme la griotte et
qui pointe des incohérences se ruent
dans le cahier des charges de la op il
ya beaucoup de choses sur lesquelles il
faut être équipé de maeyer de manière
industrielle pour faire de la fois on
m'a opéré regrette ses deux fours mais
aujourd'hui ils représentent moins de 1%
de la production de la population qui
est de 500 tonnes par an alors ils se
défendent de vouloir déstabiliser la op
mais souhaiterait une appellation qui
soutiennent davantage des installations
fermières et artisanale nous avons envie
de faire un fromage militants qui
défendent les agriculteurs un produit et
une région résume les dissidents qui
voudrais également rendre l'utilisation
du lait cru indispensable et qu'est-ce
qu'on réponde du côté de la paix alors
nous avons évidemment interrogé le
président du syndicat de la faune de
montbrison qui nous expliquait ne pas
comprendre cette démarche
cette année nous avons développé la
filière bio on a été dans leur sens on
remet des fermes et en place c'est
totalement faux de parler de
l'industrialisation se défend mme hubert
du bien et de le rappeler qu'avec 500
tonnes annuelles la fourme de montbrison
n'est pas vraiment une appellation de
grandes dimensions secondes huit
effectivement pas très loin de là à
ambert dans le département voisin du puy
de dôme
on produit chaque année 5000 tonnes une
autre forme merci beaucoup jean philippe
vigouroux peut-être voir la lune du
progrès ce matin merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous s'il y va on a vu le
progrès on va voir maintenant ce qui se
passe du côté de la presse régionale de
votre département la manche avec
alexandre pouchard
[Musique]
et alex on commence avec paris normandie
et oui le journal paris normandie qui se
demandent qui croire autour de cet
incendie de lusine lubrizol à rouen
finalement c'est une laisse un peu
planer le doute sur les informations qui
sont communiquées par l'état autour de
cet accident industriel alors que le
préfet avait d'abord assuré qu'il n'y
avait pas de toxicité aiguë des fumées
dégagées par cet incendie mais en même
temps tous les agriculteurs de la région
ne pourront plus commercialiser leurs
produits il ya donc un certain
scepticisme sûreté sur ses agents aux
scientifiques qui fournissent les
relevés à l'état un expert judiciaire en
chimie et même interrogé dans ce journal
paris normandie est à la une de ouest
france au ciri la question de lubrizol
et oui le journal ouest france pose la
question des risques pour les habitants
alors que la ministre de la transition
écologique
elisabeth borgne a assuré hier qu'il
aurait bien suivi médical de toutes les
personnes touchées par cet incendie
et quand on lit l'édition normande de
ouest france on apprend qu'un
écoquartier doit voir le jour à rouen
mais attention pas n'importe où et bien
à un kilomètre de lusine lubrizol
alors vous allez le voir cet éco
quartier était un beau projet 1 90
hectares en bord de seine 30 hectares
des espaces verts mais la proximité de
l'usiné puis surtout l'accident pourrait
remettre en cause ce projet qui pourrait
ne pas voir le jour tout simplement et
on va terminer alex avec la presse de la
manche
et oui la presse de la manche qui
s'intéressent au logement social dans le
département de la manche et qui se
demandent pourquoi ces logements hlm
sont ils si incontournable il ya de plus
en plus de logements hlm neufs qui
sortent de terre dans le département est
un exemple à cherbourg plus de 20000
habitants vivent dans des habitats à
loyer modéré si les bat on parlait merci
alex on parlait de votre département
vous avez été le président du conseil
départemental de la manche qui était
générale sera à l'époque d'ailleurs vous
comprends départementaux départementale
vous comprenez la colère de ses
présidents de départements on en parlait
tout à l'heure sur cette réforme de la
fiscalité locale dominique bussereau ne
décolère pas ça les prive d'une partie
de leurs ressources le foncier bâti pour
compenser la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation est ce que vous comprenez
cette colère de la nuit bussereau mais
je
je ne fais pas que la comprendre je la
partage c'est un jeu de vases
communicants absurdes ou supprimer
l'impôt des communes vous allez chercher
l'impôt des départements pour remplacer
l'impôt des communes vous donnez au
département une ressource qui devrait
être en réalité voté par le parlement
chaque année quand les fans mois de
l'état seront difficiles vous êtes
wrangler et le financement des
départements
vous croyez que c'est logique non la
vérité c'est que il n'ya pas d'autonomie
financière des communes des départements
et des régions
sans le pouvoir de lever l'impôt local
vous êtes dans une commune vos habitants
vous disent je vais une piscine vous
leur dites d'accord on va faire une
piscine
voilà ce que ça va coûter pour la taxe
d'habitation les gens réfléchissent en
disant peut-être que au lieu d'avoir une
piscine tout seul on devrait la faire
avec les voisins et le lien fiscal
c'est l'essence même du lien
démocratique vous ne pouvez pas gérer
une communauté
si vous responsabiliser par les lecteurs
citoyen en lui disant que les décisions
qu'on va prendre ensemble elles ont un
impact sur la peau locale et que par
conséquent il faut aux responsabilités
en discuter ensemble donc vous opposerez
à cette réforme des re stg le caltech lé
considère qu' il faut rappeler les
principes fondamentaux sans lesquels il
n'y a pas de démocratie locale et quand
il n'ya pas de démocratie locale c'est à
dire la démocratie du concret c'est la
démocratie tout court qui dépérit et je
crois qu'il faut être très vigilant là
dessus c'est bien joli personne ne se
plaindra depuis payer de taxe
d'habitation on est tous contents mais
enfin avant de distribuer des cadeaux
faut réfléchir il faut réfléchir dans
des termes qui permettent de maintenir
le civisme dans la république et le
gouvernement n'a pas assez réfléchi pour
le gouvernement c'est bien normal
il applique les promesses de campagne
enfin agir d'abord réfléchir après c'est
pas une méthode de gouvernement et nous
reste peu de temps philippe bas mais un
petit mot avec vous sur alexandre
benalla
vous avez beaucoup entendu parler
l'année dernière ils ont fait parler de
lui alexandre benalla il distille des
indices sur une possible candidature aux
municipales à saint denis qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
suhbeneba est un citoyen français et la
droite se présenter aux élections tant
qu'il n'est pas condamné à une peine qui
l'en empêche
voilà ça c'est dit un mot avant de vous
quitter sur jacques chirac car vous avez
été l'un de ses plus proches
collaborateurs fait débat secrétaire
général de l'elysée
qu'avez vous pensé des hommages rendus à
jacques chirac de ces milliers de
français qui se sont pressés pour voir
son cercueil
mais j'ai été bouleversée de voir ça et
je comprends pourquoi ayant un vécu
auprès d'annie de jacques chirac pendant
pendant si longtemps au fond moi ce que
j'ai appris personnellement me jacques
chirac sait que la compétence n'est rien
sans le coeur et sait aussi que le chef
d'état qu'il était à donner l'exemple
d'une certaine profondeur de champ il
s'intéressait à l'histoire depuis la
préhistoire jusqu'à nos jours ils
connaissaient toutes les civilisations
et quand il y avait un problème pour la
france comme le problème de la guerre en
irak
ils avaient toutes ces références tous
ses principes la connaissance des
réalités aussi et il était prêt à réagir
et à incarner le meilleur de la france
moi c'est ce que je retiens de lui bien
merci